labeling vladimir putin a killer
accusing china of genocide against the
uighur people
the biden administration has taken off
the gloves when it comes to relations
with two of the u.s main rivals with
harsh rhetoric against russia and
china the new u.s president's apparently
looking to make good on his pledge that
america is back
and won't be pushed around both rivals
responded promptly
and angrily how prepared is the u.s for
dramatic deterioration in relations
and will america's allies go along biden
confronts russia and china but can the
u.s
win
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to
greet our guests matthew karnichinik is
from the u.s
magazine politico and he says biden's
foreign policy course won't lead to
confrontation
it will help the world avoid one by
making clear to both china
and russia where the red lines are
it's great to have malta laming with us
once again he's from the berlin daily
detached beagle
and his opinion if all three big powers
abandon any sense of caution then a very
messy
escalation could follow and it's a
pleasure to welcome hangzhou
lee from dw's asia desk she thinks
china's wolf warrior diplomacy is a
mistake the more aggressive it gets
the closer the west will be drawn
together
so matthew you talk in your opening
statement about red lines
and as we all know red lines can become
an embarrassment for a leader who
doesn't
follow up with deeds
so let me ask all of you but i'll start
with matthew
how surprised have you been at the harsh
rhetoric
coming from joe biden and his
administration and is there a risk that
they're overshooting the mark
i personally don't think that they're
overshooting the mark i haven't been
surprised because i think that over the
past several years there's
been a lot of question about what u.s
foreign policy is
and what matters to the united states
when it comes to these issues
and i think this was really the goal
that biden was pursuing with this was
to say you know we do have values we're
going to fight for these values we're
going to stand up for these values
globally and to make clear that what
we've seen
over the past several years is an
anomaly and that it's not all just about
trade uh it's not all just about making
money
that the united states is still going to
stand up for people's rights for human
rights when it thinks it's necessary so
i think that the
real audience was not so much the regime
in beijing or vladimir putin but
the the public at large the the the
global public as it were
so biden essentially saying he's the not
trump hangzhou
what do you think were you surprised at
the harshness of this rhetoric
and do you think it's overshooting um
i was both surprised and not surprised
not surprised in a sense that because
biden has already made it very clear
before he became
president that um that both parties will
have to be
harsh on china so he already said that
so i wasn't surprised that um the
rhetoric has become so harsh
but i was also a little bit surprised in
the sense that um the meeting in alaska
the way that they spoke to each other in
such a such a blunt way a clear way
i was actually a little bit surprised by
that
um and i think it's important to to for
the us it was an important step for the
us
to actually make it clear to um
its audience in the domestic market so
to say in the us
and also to the audience in the eu um
that the us is back i think it's it was
the
right step for the usd we're going to
take a look at that meeting in
anchorage in a moment but first of all
same question to you
mata were you surprised and uh what do
you think about overshooting
i was a little surprised i mean
international politics and security
questions
there is sometimes a difference between
being
right and being wise you can be right
about
calling vladimir putin a killer or i
would doubt that that
the gross and harsh human rights
violation
already is something like a genocide but
but even
that the question is is it wise to do it
what purpose does it serve
and if you on on one hand serve the
the rhetoric of the communist chinese
party
because they say all what the west is
doing it's an
unsuccessful regime what the only weapon
they have is the
morality and they try to to
try to have the moral supremacy about
our system by pointing to that
it might feed just the rhetoric without
any consequence if you afterwards sit
down with them and talk business
then what what really what kind of aim
are you following with
and we want to talk in a moment about
whether it's still possible to talk a
business then
particularly in the wake of the january
attack on the u.s capitol
both russia and china have depicted the
u.s as weakened by political divisions
pandemic mismanagement and economic
instability
biden's reassertion of america's moral
authority appears designed
to prove those accusations wrong even at
the price of increasingly bitter
relations
it's the first meeting of top u.s and
chinese diplomats of the biden era
the mood is frosty
we'll also discuss our deep concerns
with actions by china
including in xinjiang hong kong taiwan
cyber attacks on the united states
economic coercion
toward our allies each of these actions
threaten the rules-based order that
maintains global stability
in response china brings up racism in
the us
rejecting any interference in its
domestic affairs
our hope is that when talking about
universal values or international public
opinion
the u.s side will think about whether it
feels entitled to say those things
because it does not represent the world
it only represents the government of the
united states
two days earlier joe biden made serious
accusations against the russian
president
in a television interview you know
vladimir putin you think he's a killer
i do so what price must he pay the price
he's going to pay well you'll see
shortly
the u.s president didn't clarify whether
he was alluding to the poisoning of
russian opposition leader alexey navalny
the response from moscow was calm
as biden said we know each other
personally
what would i reply to him i would say i
wish you health
i say that without any irony
but what is joe biden hoping to achieve
with this harsh rhetoric
matthew i want to pass that question
right on to you
you said clearly biden's signaling he's
the non-trump
but beyond that what is he looking to
achieve
and what is he likely to achieve well i
think one of the
main goals he has is to bring other
western allies
on board to the u.s position on china
and i think that is something where he's
actually already had
some progress because there had been
divisions within
sort of the western alliance about how
to approach
china and whether to look the other way
in the face of abuses like the ones
against the uyghurs
and others and i think part of this
is really directed at europe in
particular
to say we need you to come with us as we
approach china going forward because
there's been a
wholesale repositioning i would say of
the united states strategy towards china
that began
under trump already a realization that
the wealth that china now has and that
it has built up over the last 20 or 30
years is not going to result
in a more democratic china which is what
many liberals in the west had hoped
and there is i think broad consensus now
uh in the united states and
in much of europe that that's just not
going to happen china is an
authoritarian state
and we need to be prepared for the
consequences
of that and act accordingly and i think
this is what his mission is
let's talk a little bit about what the
chinese reaction was we heard
after those meetings in alaska from the
american side that behind closed doors
the tone was more civil
what did chinese leadership have to say
about the tone behind closed doors if
anything
well i think for for china um they
didn't expect
they didn't expect it to be um so
that the term would be would have been
so harsh and i think for china
it is now clear that the u.s is not
going to be
um it's ally i think because before
before the meeting
um there were still a little bit of hope
that uh the u.s
might actually still be its allies
because it's bad enough or it's not
trump it's like
a little bit more um predictable maybe
that he might be a little bit more
um he might go just go a little bit more
like
the usual diplomatic track but at the
end i think after this meeting it's just
very clear that the u.s is it's not
going down that route that it's going to
compete with china
and what are you hearing from china in
terms of
whether they think it will remain as
confrontational as it apparently was
in anchorage uh will that will there in
fact be more trade war more trade
conflict
uh essentially more of the trump
approach i think china is ready it is
ready for that
um and especially because of this
uh wolf warrior diplomacy that it
already
has been um trying to do since um 2017
it has increasingly uh been harsh
on other neighbors when like when they
were attacked and they have tried
to um like try to show
um the chinese people that tried that
china is now strong that it can compete
with the western
neighbors and i think china is going
down that route that it's focusing much
more on the domestic market
that it's um it's um driving itself away
from cooperation with the west
but try to look into the domestic market
how can
how can um people from the what
what do chinese people think in like
about china
it's much more important for them malta
biden himself has repeatedly said that
there are
certain topics and areas on which the
u.s
must cooperate with russia and china be
it arms control
be it climate change do you think that a
pragmatic approach that oscillates
between confrontation and cooperation
is actually still possible side by side
with this
maximum pressure rhetoric it is maximum
pressure there's nothing in in
international relationship that is more
powerful than accusing someone of
committing
genocide this is the strongest language
ever on the other hand i strongly hope
that both sides the chinese and the
americans
do know what you just said that they
have to cooperate on climate
on on a lot of a lot of topics
so i think that the chinese side knows
very well
that it is more or less pure symbolism
rhetoric symbolism would have said
because on on one hand what what kind of
morality are you showing if you're
accusing somebody of of committing
genocide
and talking to him for two long days in
anchorage in alaska
and uh said we had some intensive talks
and
things like that that doesn't sound very
convincing
matthew russia and the u.s actually very
quickly decided to
restart the nuclear arms
agreement start after bine's
inauguration
now following this accusation against
vladimir putin russia recalled its
ambassador from washington for the first
time
in decades won't this bitter turn in
relations
make further arms control negotiations
uh more difficult uh no i think i think
just the
opposite in fact i mean i my my read is
that the russians are probably relieved
by this because now they know
okay this is the position of the white
house
and and previously it wasn't it wasn't
clear what the position was going to be
and i think the
chinese are probably also relieved in
the sense that they know who they're
dealing with and what they're dealing
with
and the russians will look at it very
pragmatically they benefit from
the star treaties just as much as as the
us nobody wants to
you know be investing all of this money
in the nuclear
capability certainly the russians don't
i mean people forget that the
russia itself as an economy is roughly
the size of spain
uh it is it is not on the same plane as
the united states it is not on the same
plane
as china and so this is really
actually extending a hand to russia
saying look we'll renew this treaty
and there's no reason that they
shouldn't take them up on that and i
think that's also true of
of the chinese because you know china
also has uh
pressures that it has to deal with with
its domestic population
and the less money they have to spend on
on nuclear which costs a lot
the better let me pick up on the point
you made about
russia and china being in very different
places in terms of their power
trajectories
our title and much of the media
reporting about this new harsh
rhetoric hangzhou does lump together
china and russia but the fact is russia
is a declining power and china is
absolutely a rising one
what impact do you think that would have
in terms of the response that we're
likely to see
from china for example i think
i think what we're going to see is that
china and russia is going to be
closer it's they're pushing them closer
together that but china and russia they
are already cooperating
in different things like uh they have
weapon
they trade weapons and um they
they already have the kind of
relationship and i think with the harsh
rhetoric
from the us and then with the west it's
going to push them
closer together even if that's uh that
might be just
symbolic but it
just gives them the chance to stand
closer together
and malta one thing that both countries
also very much
share is insistence that other powers
including multilateral institutions like
the united
nations have no right to meddle in their
internal affairs is that what biden
essentially is doing here and are these
countries abuses of human rights
ultimately nearly impossible to
influence from outside
the question is how strong is the
language i mean the reaction that we
just saw from
vladimir putin to what biden said was
was quite telling because they know each
other because
biden was in the white house and when
obama was president barack obama was
president
when the crimean was annexed and when
the war in in ukraine starts
and things like this so um and it was
condemned to that time as well
by barack obama and in the backyard was
uh
joe biden saying yes what you did was
morally condemnable and so on and so on
so
putin knows him very well and knows what
he
what he thinks about those words and
wishing him health
is the i mean uh he's he's clearly
appealing to his older age and things
like that
so it is kind of um very self-assertive
reaction to what biden said matthew
there have been
a lot of rounds of sanctions in the past
now the u.s uh is imposing yet another
round uh on
russia but frankly so far neither harsh
rhetoric nor sanctions
appear to have really had any influence
on russia's behavior why should things
be any different now
well again you know they might not be
different in terms of russia's behavior
it might be different
however in terms of showing the rest of
the world that what russia is doing or
what china is doing is not in order
and there needs to be some kind of
reaction to it and i think that public
opinion
is very important in these questions
and it does hit obviously the
individuals
against whom the sanctions are uh
targeted uh
but sanctions also give you a
negotiating chip later on there's
something that people forget there's
never
a or very rarely a case where a
country like the united states imposes
sanctions on another country and then
the other country just sort of you know
gives up whatever it's doing but what it
does do
is that later on in negotiations we've
seen this with russia
by removing the sanctions gets you in
the negotiation
um it allows you to convince them to do
something that you don't want them to do
so i think that's that's how i would
look at it it is not the
silver bullet by any means let's talk a
little bit about
where europe is in all of this biden in
fact has repeatedly
paired his motto that the us is back
with the vow to work together with
america's european allies and indeed
earlier this week the eu joined the us
britain and canada in imposing sanctions
against
china for the first time in 30 years
as recently as december the eu signed a
new investment agreement with china
to the dismay of the united states now
it is sanctioning the country for human
rights violations
against the muslim oil minority
independent human rights organizations
estimate that one hundred thousand oygas
and other muslims are being detained and
mistreated in camps in xinjiang
for a long time the eu's top priority
was trade with beijing
now following the example of the us
brussels is also playing hardball
we have taking decisive actions against
responsible for serious human rights
violations
and abuses in six countries
the census that the council adopted
today concern
11 individuals and four entities from
china
north korea libya south sudan
eritrea and russia
for their role in persecuting lgbt plus
people brussels is stepping up sanctions
against russian officials
most recently the imposed sanctions on
russia over the poisoning of now
imprisoned kremlin opponent
alexei navalny by imposing sanctions the
u.s and the european union are slowly
tightening the screws
but how much further is europe really
willing to go
let me put that question uh to mata
malte in your opening statement
you said that none of the three powers
russia china or the u.s
has a real interest in escalation but
the fact is that is a
very much a european perspective europe
in general and germany in particular
have repeatedly
made it clear that they are very
concerned about being forced to
essentially
take sides in a u.s china
cold war and possibly also in u.s
hostility
versus vis-a-vis russia do you think
that's what's happening here is
is the eu now with these latest uh
sanctions against china essentially
being forced to take sides in a way yes
and i would i would always say uh
if it's through through partnerships or
through nato
or through other institutions there's
always a very strong link between
european union and the united states and
it
and even if it's for the security of
europe i mean we are still
relying on on on the american nuclear
umbrella
for that so there is and we are
democracies that binds us together we
share the same values
the question is um the threat of
escalation
uh we have the experience from the cold
war and we were always afraid about
escalating things and um
all three countries a member of the
united nations security council
all three are nuclear powers so there is
never a military solution for any kind
of conflict
so i i think that sanctions became
just another tool of international
diplomacy it doesn't really hurt
the country it never functions very well
with one exception that was south africa
but all other countries like from sudan
through libya through serbia
all others never it never worked it does
it will not bring
the chinese communist party to to
collapse
let me ask feng shui she agrees with
that and
is there joint action on the part of the
u.s and europe that could
influence china's behavior um i do agree
that um the sanctions are largely
symbolic because it was just
um against a few people which won't
bring
much effect really but um i think that
um
the action itself uh the symbolic action
itself
it's a big step because for europe it
has
it was so reluctant to actually take any
stance and
as you've already said it's the first
time in 30 years and i think that's a
big
and i think that's a big step it's a big
decision for them to take
and in terms of and um to answer your
question if that's going to change
china's behavior i don't think these
sanctions can change china's behavior
to be honest but um if the u.s
continues this course and to con and if
they can connect
uh the western powers to get uh western
power together
and people who have the same country
sorry
who which have the same beliefs and
combine that economic power together
i think that's going to have an effect
but in this
triangle let's say china on one hand
united states and europe on the other
hand
europe is the weakest link so there is a
temptation
for the chinese to say if if you want a
kind of battle
we go for the weakest link not for the
strong competitor united states
matthew how far do you think europe will
be willing to go
uh particularly with that awareness of
how dependent it is
on on china's market well i think
germany is very dependent on the chinese
market the rest of europe is not as
dependent
on chinese market china's the largest
trading partner now for the eu i believe
although it's mainly because they export
so much from china they're not selling
as much
to china as they are to the united
states for example the united states is
a more important export market for
europe as a whole
so uh europe is as marty said
very reliant on the us in various ways
especially for its security
i think that uh the fact that it has
kind of come around on china
is uh more a sign that they are
accepting the reality
as it is and that's why things like
sanctions i would argue
are important because it creates moral
clarity
and i think as recently as december when
the eu was doing this investment
deal with china there was a feeling of
well the chinese you know they're not
nice to the uyghurs but
you know they're they're also you know
the the americans aren't nice to certain
people too
and and there's sort of bad things going
on everywhere which is you know
kind of a kind of justification i think
in a lot of europeans minds for
continuing on the previous course that
has gone out the window now so you can
see that
biden's approach the pressure that
lincoln is
is exerting behind the pressure is
already having an effect
very briefly almost out of time but
quickly from you and also from malta
north stream bringing it back to russia
is it
time if we're talking about serious
pressure and working together with the
u.s for
germany to put the gas pipeline
nordstrom
that essentially is a deal with russia
to rest
i think it is i don't think germany will
do it because it has
refused to do it for so long melted yes
uh germany
it is um relies on north stream because
they get rid of nuclear power and coal
powered so
this gas is the only thing that's left
to fulfill his needs
uh and energy-wise so it's not going to
happen in your view
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us uh
here today and thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you